[音楽]
なぜのああ
しています
で本日のテストですがベスト時間が50分となっています
教養問題の穴なんですけれども結婚を真剣にとパンできないというところと時間が勝負
というゲストになっておりますのでなるべく多くの問題をつけるようになっていって
ください
どいつもこいつも舐めた顔しやがってん
俺はこのクラスで髪の毛の毛量が多いからってみんなからいじられている
最近それがヒートアップしていきたいとだんだん悪化してきて俺はとても教室にづらい
んだ
えっ
現在なんだ
ああああああ
もう限界だ俺はもう懸命な
許さないと思い立ち
どうなっても知らないからなぁ
上お前たちに
[音楽]
小文字で対抗する今日のチェストのために俺はたくさんの電気ビリビリペンを準備した
これは特別な改造がしてありノックするとさん10万ボルトの電流が流れ
関連してしまうっていうやつだあっはぁ
これを使ってこら前地獄に叩け落としてるよはさあ
全部ちゃんと電流が流れないか自分で全部てっとしたいや集かと思ったぜええっ
まあいいだろう
これであいつらに
日頃の復習ができるわけだからなはっはっは
あっはーん
こいつら g 意義はから電流流れること知らないんだぜ
敗目近所素敵だなあ
晩婚みたい一つのしやがってよお前ら今からどんなが起こってるんだろうなーぜ塩
雰囲気だぜ
ぱぱぱぱーん
本陣前覚えは水くる所に顔が見れるなんてのはパラパーンッ
をテスト用紙とペンが配られるみたいだな
うちの学校は還元率が95%とから
カンニングしないようにペンまで支給されるんだよ
だから変わったんだったよ
いや楽しみだ
あーおっとっと感じですだから今たんだったよ
このテープで配られるペンを全て俺が全部した電気ビリビリれてにすり替えだけでお前
ら銭でずっとの開始時にフィリぶりだぜ
あとは z かーしゃ待つだけだ
緊張してきたので俺のことを何な奴には申し訳ないが今回はクラス全員し見えてもらう
ぜ
さーん中国のショーの始まりだ
[音楽]
13分になったもここから50分間
ています
8位あれ
[音楽]
can
amaran
あれ
楽しそうなんだけど
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
そのまま差し返していたらねぇ縮小とに
てくだ
me
ハーイが開いた頸椎まーすっています
酔ったおーはー
の今日のところは
金武町立ネイバー
border
[拍手]